story about a Newport Beach couple
a young guy good looking couple young a
surgeon and his wife and they're
apparently swingers and they got in
trouble because they went to a bar and
they picked up these women and then
brought them back to their place and the
women say that they kind of came too the
women think that they were drugged and
that these this couple this young
surgeon and his wife were actually
preying on them
and and we're drugging them to get
involved into all sorts of weird stuff
back at their place and so when the
women came to they said we got to get
out of here whatever and they left and
they they go after them well the charges
were just dropped against the Newport
Beach surgeon and his girlfriend
and the question in the case is
were they swingers or predators in fact
that's this article here on Yahoo News
asks that very question were they
swingers or were they Predators was it
just fun kind of consensual gallivanting
or was there something dark and
nefarious here
and my question is what's the difference
what's the difference really
they're I'm not saying there's no
distinction whatsoever between the two
cases but in both cases they're
predators in both cases this Newport
Beach couple is not going out to will
the good of these other women and to
edify them and build them up and care
for them and take care of their needs
and get married to them or anything like
that they're just going out to satisfy
their own base appetites and to use
women in the process and maybe they
cross the line even further and Drug
these women and are in some other way
kind of coerced them but maybe they just
merely seduced them at a bar and took
them back and used their bodies and then
threw them out on the street
either way though that's predatory
behavior
in fact the old ancient Greeks go to all
Uncle Plato talked about this too and
said that
uh rape physical rape is in fact less
severe than seduction today in our
modern society we think that's crazy
what are you talking about seduction
that's just that's consensual but rape
you know that's one of the worst crimes
yeah rape is one of the worst crimes but
the reason that our old ancient Greek
buddies thought that is because
a physical rape is just a violation of
the body a seduction is a violation not
only of the body but also the intellect
and of the Soul it pierces much much
deeper that's the kind of behavior that
they're engaging in it's the kind of
behavior that's totally enshrined in our
society and it's enshrined in feminism
and it's enshrined in the sexual
Revolution and it's an idea that that as
long as you can get someone to meekly
mutter yes that you have the right to do
whatever you want to satisfy your own
base desires it's an idea of pure
selfishness and it's an idea of
predation and predatory behavior a
swingers are predators what's the
difference right now go to geniusell.com
sold out of their Dark Spot Corrector
and our listeners have been begging for
a restock begging on their hands and
knees well I've got great news just in
time for the summer
it's back geniusell's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has not won but three Cutting
Edge ingredients and goes to work fast
to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots and even old discoloration both on
your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniuselle's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed how quickly you will
see results or 100 of your money goes
back guaranteed go to genucel.com
Knowles right now get your dark spot
corrector in the geniusell most popular
package that is geniusell.com Knowles
right now save over seventy seven zero
percent off Junior cell's most popular
package all orders will include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
geniusell.com
Knowles speaking of
Newport Beach place is known for
fundraising
our friend Vivek ramaswamy not a swinger
to my knowledge I'm not don't draw the
wrong conclusion from that transition I
was transitioning onto political
fundraising nothing to do with the weird
Newport Beach couple uh the vague
Vivek has a very novel idea for how to
raise money for his presidential
campaign
here it is
this campaign is founded on the truth
here's the truth of how political
fundraising actually works there's a
tiny group it's an oligopoly of people
who raise money bundling and otherwise
who get to keep a large percentage
sometimes up to ten percent of what they
actually raise
that doesn't make any sense to belong to
a small group of people I don't like
this system as it exists but if that's
the system we're going to have my view
is let's democratize that and make it
possible for everybody to make money as
well so if you're supporting me and
you're part of this movement and you
want to help us actually raise that
money
join my kitchen cabinet new program
we're launching where you help me raise
the money you get a unique link to do it
we'll have a special relationship I'm
going to keep giving you phone calls
telling you how I think you can be most
effective for us but the money you raise
you get to keep ten percent of it
I love it I think it's a great idea he's
right
in that there is a class of people
called political fundraisers and they
work for these campaigns and they raise
a boatload of money and they get to keep
a decent chunk of it themselves as their
job
so he's saying why are we doing this why
are we creating this professional class
of political Consultants politics is
supposed to be about you it's supposed
to be about ordinary citizens and
personal connections so I'm going to
increase that personal connection to you
and I'm going to incentivize you don't
we support Market incentives here on the
right yeah I think we do don't we do
that in America yeah I think we do so
we're going to incentivize you to raise
some money some people are disingenuous
like calling this a pyramid scheme this
is not a pyramid scheme at all a pyramid
scheme is where you
you sell some stupid product and then
you you convince other people not only
to buy your product but to sell that
product for you and then you get a cut
of of what that person sells and then
they do it and they do it and they do it
it keeps going on and on and on and the
idea is you build up this kind of funnel
into a pyramid
it's not any anything even close to what
Vivek is saying he's just saying hey if
you raise some money for me you get 10
percent
that's it
no pyramid no multi-layer no you just
whatever you raise you get 10 I think
this is a great idea and the best part
of this
it's not that he's raising money Vivek
doesn't need money he's a very wealthy
man it's not that
I don't know that people are going to
make a ton of money on the people might
make some money but they're not going to
make an insane amount of money on this
the best part of it is that he's trying
something new he's shaking up the race
in his campaign promises in the way he's
conducting the race and even in the way
he's conducting the operations of the
campaign even not not just the way he's
conducting social media ads but the way
he's conducting fundraising he's he's
coming to this race with the out of the
box vision of an entrepreneur which is
what he is and this is why he keeps
jumping up the ranks in this race of a
fake right now nationally is in third
place and the this is the the biggest
positive probably about vivek's
presidential campaign and it's so
shocking that this guy who pretty much
nobody had heard of six months ago is
now the number three guy in the GOP race
for president and it's the biggest knock
on the number two guy in the race Ronda
Santos who's got so many great things
going for him he's a very impressive
person he's very intelligent he's done a
great job in Florida he would probably
make a great president but his campaign
is stuck in the Rut for precisely this
reason all Vivek is doing is just trying
new stuff shaking things up throw in
spaghetti at the wall and all the
DeSantis campaign seems to be doing is
doubling down on a strategy that is
slowly losing them support and if they
don't turn it around it's going to
seriously hamper their chances if not
totally foreclose their chances of
making it to the nomination boy wasn't
that a great clip now make sure you ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time